get the hell out of here mom stop this  is your mother oh goody persuading you  to help me is gonna be easier than I fun  helping you do what your underground  stays already been destroyed I'm still  going forward so what you kill my mother  if I don't help you destroy the world  news flash my mother lives in the world  dime instantaneously in nuclear fire  rather painless and then there's having  your life force slowly sucked out like  this what's gonna be miss Smoak  look I know you don't live here anymore  but those were nice windows so  unoriginal I am now powered by the  deaths of tens of thousands of souls  there is nothing you can do to stop me  or should I say us  era the season finale tonight eight  seven central on the CW